[Music]
why not
this is timothy hammond a houston-based
gardener who knows his arugula
i'm an urban gardener and educator and
one thing i know is that you'll never
find anybody in this world who loves
gardening more than i do
so what better person to help us test
this the rise gardens family garden
as people spent more time at home during
the pandemic
demand has searched for activities like
cooking home improvement
and yes gardening so that's why we're
testing the rise garden smart garden
it's an indoor smart garden that uses
hydroponics
it allows you to grow up to 12
vegetables and herbs per shelf
using a self-watering system and grow
lights i'm interested to see if
this garden this rise garden produces
better than some plants that i'm going
to start at the same time outside
so why did we pick this smart garden a
few reasons
this smart garden is designed for small
indoor spaces and claims to grow larger
vegetables
not just herbs and leafy greens it's
also adjustable
the modular system lets you add shelves
up to three different growing levels
it's wi-fi enabled with a connected app
so you can control the light
water and nutrient levels and get
reminder alerts and updates
so i've never really thought about
bringing my gardening inside
now they promised that you will be able
to recreate outdoor
harvest inside the rice garden systems
come in three sizes
ranging in price from 549 dollars to 949
dollars
there's also a smaller personal garden
for 279
the one timothy is testing is 749
but is it worth it timothy has more than
four weeks to test out the smart garden
and give us his final review
here we are and i guess now it's time
to start gardening
timothy first assessed the planting
process with the garden
arugula should sprout in five days they
say
now some of these seed cups say that
these things
like the lettuce or the arugula or the
basil will take anywhere from
five to eight days to sprout then he
planted his own seeds outside to compare
let's go ahead and pot up some basil
some arugula and some lettuce so i can
tell you
one of the benefits of using that rise
garden is you don't have to deal with
this intense heat
so you're probably able to grow things a
variety of things year round
now we'll set these in a shaded area and
we'll check back in about a week or so
to see if these sprouted at the same
time as our rise garden
[Music]
next he gauged how easy the garden is to
maintain
i think the flashing lights means it's
working
ha your garden is connected ah
look at the lights dimming it's testing
the lights
the fact that it sends me alerts through
an app is pretty cool
i mean it makes it a lot easier to
remember things involved with the garden
and that's one thing that we really want
is to make sure that we
are staying on top of it and the app
helps you stay on top of the gardening
so today we're going to do a reservoir
change change the water out in the
reservoir
because you can check the water level
now we're down to two
and then we're actually gonna throw in
i'm gonna throw in some of these
nutrients here
i'm excited check out the arugula
taking off okay
once you put the nutrients in i think it
was about a week and a half in about 10
days in once i put the nutrients in
and stuff really started taking off
finally he compared how the same seeds
grew outside in comparison to the smart
garden
this is day two with rye's garden and i
wanted to show you that the seeds that
we planted outside have already sprouted
we already have some arugula sprouting
while the rise garden has still not
sprouted
nothing beats the sun and mother nature
we have
some basil sprouting in the nursery up
here
which is pretty cool but let's take a
look at the rest of the garden
see we have basil sprouting here also
that's on the top
shelf so how did the outdoor seeds
ultimately compare
so as you can see here the ones that we
had outside they have to deal with the
elements
while they were the first to sprout they
quickly
stalled and slowed down once that
hundred degree weather
that hundred degree houston weather came
into account
so what's timothy's final take after 25
days
so when it comes to this rise garden
smart garden i'd give it a 4 out of 5.
first i love how well it grows leafy
greens
i love how simple it is to use i love
the app
keeping up with when i planted and when
i need to do water changes and things
like that
but a few things that i don't like with
the system
first i don't like that the shelves are
not adjustable
meaning i have to put my taller plants
on the bottom and also
they get less light down on the bottom
second it's not easy to clean out the
reservoir
and empty and change the water whenever
it's time for water changes
and third thing is the price at over 700
dollars
that's a little too steep for me but i
love what this garden is able to do
and i love the fact that you could grow
year-round with this thing
a rise garden spokesman said the purpose
of the shelf height is to keep the
structure simple and refined
they're also working on improving the
cleaning process he added while the
price point is quite high for a
hobby-like gardening
we really wanted to not cut corners on
materials and technology
in order to allow people to go from a
fun hobby to truly replacing items on
their grocery list
and just like that give a nice bowl of
salad greens right here
you